guys eSports has grown exponentially
over the last few years we went from the
basements of convention halls to major
sports stadiums around the world
sometimes kind of feels like we made it
now that doesn't mean though that even
now we don't hit the occasional hiccup
along the way and by occasional hiccup I
mean massive scandal here are the top 10
scandals in eSports starting us off is
the insane story of the implosion of
echo fox which led to Rick Fox's
departure from eSports
after months of scandal behind the
scenes in April 2000 19 eSports
journalist Richard Lewis reported that
an unnamed shareholder used racial slurs
in a conversation with one of Echo Fox's
co-owners Jace Hall after more reports
came out about the shareholder later
identified as I meet rosada Rick Fox
broke his silence and told TMZ that he
was out unless echo Fox could remove
Rosanna
he's been my life this has been my
passion and looking to go anywhere but I
will not stay in a business with a
racist law
from allegations of threats racism and
drug use the war for the soul of echo
Fox raged on as the entire org burned to
the ground
unfortunately in the end echo Fox was
forced to sell their LCS slot and
officially dissolved just how do you
feel oh I feel yeah I feel so completely
bent over I feel unappreciated
I feel unheard I feel angry I feel
disrespected I feel sad coming in at
number nine is a situation that led to a
player being banned from an entire city
2018 proved to be a tumultuous year for
TNC predator player cuckoo who found
himself in hot water after using a slur
against Chinese players in a pub match
news of the insult spread like wildfire
in the Chinese dota community and with a
major coming up in Chongqing China the
government banned the Filipino player
from attending back to the official word
players and teams will make mistakes in
the future and they should accept
responsibility for them we weren't there
to be operative
to learn from their errors but taking
responsibility doesn't mean making
mistakes don't come without a cost
according to TNC the government told
them they could not quote guarantee
KooKoo safety should he attend the major
it's hard - these guys are young and
some of them you might even call kids so
to have like this negative energy
directed against you it's I think it was
hard this incident ignited a war within
the DOTA community with valve even
coming under fire for supposedly
pandering to the Chinese government and
kuku was subsequently banned from the
major yeah he got banned from the same
event twice coming in at number 8 is yes
again the Olaf boost look it's on every
top-10 list we've ever done for a reason
it's undeniable that at the time the
play took place the entire CS world held
their breath as the best two teams in
the world bought for supremacy at
dreamhack winter 2014 fnatic was down on
overpass after being smashed 12 3 in the
first half by ldl-c and while the
audience at home thought all hope was
lost fnatic still had one trick up their
sleeve all of my sister is still waiting
the patients came coming I can spot them
coming out of suite dollars while he's
here he sees them down there straight
heads up they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed oh it
finally works and now phonetic if this
is the combat home what has come to be
known as the Olaf boost left ldl-c well
it left them confused and dazed let's
say fnatic won the map and the series
but their win was immediately called
into question do Jeep I think it's fair
I mean I feel sorry for the ALC guys
because they played an amazing match
they played way better than we actually
did but we had more knowledge about the
map so we won because of that Dreamhack
staff reviewed the play and determined
that the Olaf boost was illegal a remake
was called fnatic chose to forfeit and
the rest is history
history that gets told and every the
score eSports top ten list taking the
number seven spot on our list is a cry
for freedom that set the Blizzard world
ablaze in October 2000 nineteen after a
match in the hearthstone grandmasters
series Taiwan blitz Jung gave a
post-match interview and yelled liberate
Hong Kong revolution of our age on
stream his statement was in support of
the protests occurring in Hong Kong at
the time where locals took to the
streets to oppose mainland China's
influence on their government Blizzard
proceeded to take down the vaad band
blitz Chung and the casters who
interviewed him for a year and made him
forfeit around $4,000 of prize money
people were pissed and blizzard was
forced to respond though few were
satisfied with their apology we didn't
live up to the high standards that we
really set for ourselves and the second
is we failed in our purpose
and for that I am sorry and I accept
accountability which Jung got his prize
money back and his band was cut to six
months but his story made international
headlines it led to people canceling
their Blizzard accounts and to
governments making statements about the
company's actions now we also had some
condemnation from US politicians
stepping into this as I did with the MBA
controversy that includes a Senator
Wyden who's a Democrat mind you he says
a blizzard shows it it's willing to
humiliate itself to please the Chinese
Communist Party no American company
should censor calls for freedom to make
a quick buck the number six spot belongs
to the insane saga of how one of the
League of Legends most promising teams
exploded this is one of the most complex
scandals in eSports and if you want more
info you can watch one of the five
videos we've already made to explain the
situation but the end result of the
whole mess is that Gryphon an
up-and-coming team full of exciting
players was basically torn apart in a
feud between their manager and their
coach a minor was allegedly tricked into
signing a terrible contract players were
allegedly physically and verbally abused
and we still don't know the full story
sword one of the players on Griffin also
says quote he also said I'm disgusting
and that he can't handle me he said that
if we lose because of me he follow me to
the end of the world to get revenge or
that he'd kill me as a result of this
whole mess Griffin was fined along with
the manager and the coach who were also
banned from competitive league plus a
Korean senator put Griffin on blast and
is currently pushing for a complete
overhaul of Korean eSports contracts
taking the number five spot on our list
we have the fall of one of the greatest
careers in StarCraft two life was one of
the most accomplished Starcraft two
players of his day and became known as
the god of the game at just 15 years old
but all of that success came crashing
down in 2016 when life was arrested the
Korean police found that life
participated in a Starcraft 2 match
fixing ring sending shockwaves
throughout Korean eSports one of the two
pro gamers arrested as part of this
investigation is Knight
year-old life the arrest a former
Blizzard world champion Lee life son
hyung has been followed with an
indictment life was fined roughly forty
two thousand two hundred dollars in
today's currency and sentenced to 18
months in jail at just 19 years old to
put this in perspective the korean court
ruled that the damage to the eSports
industry was so great that it had
weighed the fact that he was a minor
when he committed the crimes which meant
he got no Appeals the fact that the
world champion ended up throwing matches
as well as a couple of other players
that we know of and obviously while I
did get prosecuted and all that
obviously did her to Korean saying a lot
that one decision destroyed his career
and annihilated his legacy as one of the
greatest players to ever touch Starcraft
2
putain starcraft a world-champion
started
the saga of T Fuu and faze clan is one
of the biggest controversies in eSports
and streaming history and that's why
it's coming in at number four on our
list in 2019 T Fuu was on top of the
world he was one of the biggest
streamers on Twitch but behind the
scenes things weren't as rosy between T
Fuu and his org this is a video that
absolutely no one at Fay's plan ever
wanted to make because it's going to
shed some negative light on a guy that
we care a lot about but he's forced this
upon us in May 2009 teen Teague sued
phase why well according to T Fu's legal
team his contract with one of the gaming
world's biggest orgs was quote grossly
oppressive onerous and one-sided first
of all why why are we sitting around
believing that they only took sixty
thousand dollars you know how you could
rely on their $60,000 figure as to what
they made off him it's disingenuous I
mean you realize how much money
today's clan is making by having Turner
as part of its team how much advertising
they're selling how many sponsorships
that they obtained because Turner was
part of their team it's almost laughable
now for their part phase said they've
been trying to make T Fuu happy and
renegotiate his contract for months and
were caught off guard and blindsided by
the law see we've already said we
haven't taken any money from you guys
this is a guy he's probably made he's
made certainly 1520 million dollars
since he's signed with us right he's
personally made money someone is gonna
be somewhere around that around those
lovers at this point the lawsuit is
still ongoing
in fact it's mushroomed into two
different lawsuits in two different
states but no matter what happens with
either one thing is for sure the results
will have a profound impact on eSports
and streamer contracts in the future
these kids are getting ripped off
they're getting taken advantage of these
contracts are not okay and this reason
never happened again and there's tons of
people in contracts this bad just like
me and I'm the first person to stand up
and say this is [ __ ] this is not right
this is not cool this is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no list of eSports controversies would
be complete without the most notorious
match-fixing scandal in counter-strike
history the ibuypower scandal which is
why it's coming in at number 3 on our
list in August 2014 I by power one of
the best teams in North America played a
match against the team called netcode
guides during season five of the SIBO
pro league it's something about that
match just felt off and it's very weird
to see steel opping over skadoodle i
don't know if schedules not feeling it
right now or what is going on but I by
power is definitely not playing like
ibuypower
doesn't go for the shot he's gonna try
and get the flank off he's gonna have
two right there can they line up for him
what is he doing why did he hesitate so
much doesn't matter has this easy gets
one gets taken down Hayes was so very
low they lined up perfectly for him but
for some reason he says he wanted
tonight just a few months later eSports
journalist Richard Lewis reported that
iBUYPOWER had thrown the match and
placed nine bets and 1193 dollars each
four of the five I buy power players
were subsequently banned permanently the
community still argues about whether or
not the ban was justified and what NACS
could have looked like if the throw had
never happened
ya know get bucks days sorry bro
you're the ringleader you should burn
and I'm just so sad that you [ __ ]
brats wagon with this [ __ ] with you that
you took advantage of a [ __ ] young
star that was that had everything ahead
of them and that he could he could have
[ __ ] gone on to become one of the
best North American players of all time
the [ __ ] dominate worldwide and you
ruined that unfortunately we'll just
never know as none of the banned players
have been let back into valve sanctioned
competition their bans left a gaping
hole in North American CS one that took
years to fill
[Applause]
Xavier was a bourgeois one of the
greatest players to ever touch Starcraft
he was adored and revered but his legacy
was destroyed by one of the highest
profile match-fixing scandal z' eSports
has ever seen
which is why Savior comes in at number 2
on our list yeah so at the time I was
like super shocking when the mass fixing
scandal broke and food or not just
because you know it was match-fixing but
it was because it was so players and not
only was it like a live in like big tier
players
it was involves a viewer who was at the
time up I want to say like top 5
greatest player of all time in terms of
both like results and popularity in May
2010 an investigation concluded that
several Starcraft players including
savior were participating in a massive
match-fixing ring it was one of the
first match-fixing scandal that extended
beyond a handful of isolated players
which meant that punishments were severe
Savior got two years probation 120 hours
of community service and had all his
domestic titles and trophies taken away
from him all that's left of his legacy
now is the deep disappointment of his
fans who still wonder how he could have
stooped so low oh my god he's put cigar
she-bear no Nielsen job sorry I'm
kidding
Amiata hendren Tier II spot um can and
can get an idea there's only one thing
bigger than match-fixing and that's the
destruction of an entire gray market
gambling economy that's right the number
one spot on our list is going to the
valve crackdown on csgo skin gambling
market by 2016 csgo had developed a skin
market worth an estimated five billion
dollars people would gamble using skins
and chips but without any government
oversight skin gambling was open to
minors and to people in parts of the
world where gambling was illegal because
valve has helped to create an
unregulated international gambling
concerned with no oversight that targets
teenagers plaintiffs and the class have
been damaged their kids lost money and
the parents came together saying well
this is illegal why are you allowing my
kids to gamble the cs community was
sitting on a time bomb that was ticking
down to a legal nightmare and in july
that time bomb blew up he all started
with team martin and pro syndicate two
popular youtubers who are advertising a
skin gambling web site on their channel
but didn't disclose the very important
fact that they owned it I've been
starting to bed a little bit more like
Brock's like obviously you guys know he
loves Betty he's posted a ton of betting
videos on his channel and stuff and he's
been hitting me up and we found this new
site called csgo lotto so I'll link it
down in description if you guys want to
check it out but we were betting on it
today and I won a pot of like $69 or
something like that so it's a pretty
small pot but it was like the coolest
feeling ever the resulting scandal blew
the lid off the entire skin betting
ecosystem valve had to hand out 23
cease-and-desist to skin gambling
websites dealt with class-action
lawsuits and even fielded an
investigation from the Washington state
Gambling Commission the lawsuits haven't
stopped yet and valve had to change the
way the skin market worked to limit
gambling the entire situation even
prompted governments all over the world
to take a closer look at skin gambling
and loot boxes which has even led to
laws being enacted in some countries
we're looking at legislation this coming
year which could prohibit access or
prohibit the sale of these games to
folks who are underage in order to
protect families as well as prohibiting
different kinds of mechanisms in those
games I think the games industry should
accept a much more proactive
responsibility it gathers the data about
how people play how much they spend it
can it can identify the outliers people
who maybe are suddenly play a lot more
or for a long period of time been
playing a lot more and I think it should
take an interest in the welfare of those
players no other eSports scandal had
this kind of worldwide impact and it's
hard to imagine and you will again well
guys that's our list of the top ten
scandals in all of eSports now if you
want to know more about any of the
individual entries when we've done
entire videos on almost every one so
check those out sub to the channel like
this video and comment below and I'll
see you next week you know how they
always say like we're made of stars like
human beings are literally a way for the
universe to know itself the Sun is so
hot
it creates nuclear attracting forces
like most of the universe was comprised
of hydrogen right and then when those
molecules like going to Suns you know
right up to uranium while the naturally
occurring elements we find in our
universe it's amazing it's [ __ ]
incredible eSports was made in stars
dude come on